(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) A segunda aba aqui da calculadora é a
aba de pagamento financiado.
O pagamento financiado é possível no leilão extrajudicial.
A DIV vai estudar isso melhor no módulo
2, mas o edital do leilão pode estipular
o pagamento financiado e aí o edital do
leilão vai estipular as regras daquele financiamento, como
o prazo máximo que você pode financiar e
também a taxa de juros que vai ter
naquele financiamento.
Arrematar um imóvel utilizando o financiamento é uma
boa forma de você diminuir o capital mínimo
para você ingressar nos leilões, afinal de contas
você não vai precisar do valor todo a
vista e é perfeitamente possível que você venda
o imóvel que está financiado logo após o
leilão.
Tem uma aula explicando melhor sobre isso no
módulo 2, que é de leilões extrajudiciais.
E também é uma forma de você diversificar
o seu capital.
Vamos supor que você tem ali 300 mil
para arrematar imóveis.
Você poderia comprar um imóvel à vista com
esse valor, mas utilizando esse valor também você
pode fazer algumas arrematações financiadas, como de dois
ou três imóveis, dependendo ali do valor.
Quando a gente fala da arrematação de um
único imóvel à vista ou financiado, obviamente que
no à vista o valor de lucro vai
ser maior, porque você não vai ter juros
incidindo ali sobre a sua compra.
Isso para um imóvel único.
Agora quando a gente fala da compra de
um imóvel através de um financiamento e aí
mais imóveis com o mesmo valor que você
compraria um único à vista, no final o
lucro somado dessas compras financiadas vai ser maior
do que o seu lucro à vista muito
provavelmente.
Então vale aí você fazer essa conta de
acordo com o valor que você tem para
gastar e de acordo com os seus interesses
e da sua possibilidade também de financiar ou
não um imóvel.
Então a calculadora do financiamento está aqui e
para a calculadora do financiamento a gente tem
duas regras que a gente pode aplicar ali
para o financiamento, que é optar pela tabela
price no financiamento ou optar pela tabela SAC
no financiamento.
Quais são as diferenças entre as duas tabelas?
A tabela SAC, que é de sistema de
amortização constante, ela tem uma característica de começar
com uma parcela maior e essa parcela diminuindo
ao longo do financiamento.
Então você começa pagando mais juros e no
final os juros vão ficando menores e a
sua parcela vai diminuindo.
Já na tabela price as parcelas são constantes
do começo ao fim do parcelamento.
Então você não começa pagando mais para diminuir
esse parcelamento ao final ali do seu prazo
de financiamento.
Então essa é a principal diferença entre as
duas.
Para quem quiser arrematar de forma financiada também
vai ter uma diferença entre optar pela tabela
SAC e optar pela tabela price como a
gente vai fazer uma demonstração prática aqui nessa
calculadora do financiamento.
O que você precisa saber?
Quando a gente compra um imóvel para carregar
esse financiamento até o final, vários estudos indicam
que é melhor você recorrer à tabela SAC,
porque ao final, considerando todo aquele valor pago
naquele financiamento, a tabela SAC vai ficar muito
mais barata do que a tabela price.
Só que o nosso objetivo aqui como leilão,
optando por um financiamento, não é carregar o
financiamento até o final, é pagar ali aquele
financiamento de repente por 12 meses até que
a venda do imóvel seja concluída.
Então você precisa analisar se vai ser melhor
no seu caso optar pela tabela SAC ou
pela tabela price.
Vamos aqui então para análise prática da opção
de financiamento e vamos comparar tabela price com
tabela SAC para vocês entenderem a diferença ali
na prática de que significa optar por uma
ou optar por outra.
Vamos continuar com os mesmos valores que a
gente simulou para compra vista?
Então vamos lá.
Valor de arrematação, 200 mil.
Valor de venda, 400 mil.
Porcentagem de entrada, geralmente a gente paga 20
% do valor da arrematação como entrada.
Existem alguns casos excepcionais da caixa que você
consegue arrematar com 5% do valor da
entrada.
Se fosse o caso era só você mudar
aqui que a calculadora já automaticamente faria a
conta, mas vou deixar 20% que é
a regra ali do financiamento.
Quando você coloca 20% do valor como
entrada, a calculadora te apresenta aqui o valor
em reais que você vai precisar dessa entrada.
Então com o valor de arrematação de 200
mil com 20% de entrada, você precisaria
de 40 mil reais ali da entrada.
O restante, os outros 80% seriam financiados
correspondendo a 160 mil reais.
Taxa de juros anual, vou colocar aqui 8%.
Prazo de financiamento.
Taxa de juros e prazo de financiamento você
vai encontrar no edital do leilão.
Isso pode mudar de edital para edital e
aí você vai lá verificar.
No nosso caso aqui coloquei 8% de
taxa de juros anual e no prazo de
financiamento a gente consegue encontrar hipóteses de até
420 meses, né, mas pode ter de 240,
360, 420, então você precisa sempre verificar no
edital do leilão.
Vamos fazer uma simulação aqui com 360 meses.
Comissão do leiloeiro, via de regra 5%, já
tá aqui e TBI simulando que aqui em
São Paulo 3% do valor da arrematação,
o registro 1930.
Não teve valor do advogado que você fez
um acordo para desocupar aquele imóvel.
Teve um valor de reforma de 3 mil
e um valor de outros de mil reais
que é a mudança que você pagou para
que a pessoa saísse do imóvel de forma
rápida.
Prazo de venda.
12 meses, é o que eu sempre coloco.
IPTU mensal, já estava aqui, 100 reais.
Condomínio mensal, 400 reais e aqui ele te
apresenta os valores totais desse IPTU e desse
condomínio.
Aqui na aba de calculadora financiada a gente
tem uma diferença que é o total do
financiamento que você vai pagar e aí tem
diferença entre a tabela price e tabela saque.
Então veja, a gente colocou aqui 12 meses
da venda, né, do prazo real de venda
entre a arrematação até o momento que você
for vender aquele imóvel.
Durante esses 12 meses, além de condomínio e
IPTU, você tem que pagar de fato aquele
financiamento daquele imóvel.
Você não pode deixar de pagar esse financiamento
senão esse imóvel pode novamente voltar a leilão.
Então você vai pagar essas parcelas mês a
mês até que você venda o imóvel.
A calculadora ela te apresenta aqui o valor
que você vai ter que pagar na tabela
price e na tabela saque.
E aqui entra a grande diferença.
Eu falei que na tabela saque você começa
pagando mais e as parcelas vão diminuindo ao
longo do financiamento.
E eu falei que na tabela price você
paga do começo ao fim a mesma parcela.
Por isso que tem diferença aqui.
Se você optar pela tabela saque, você vai
precisar de um valor maior para manter aquele
imóvel da arrematação até a venda.
Se você optar pela tabela price, você vai
precisar de um valor menor da arrematação até
a venda.
Mas para a gente tirar uma conclusão mesmo,
vamos continuar aqui na calculadora.
Soma total de custos é o que você
vai pagar de entrada, o que você vai
pagar de TBI, de registro, comissão do leiloeiro
e aí o que você vai pagar para
manter o imóvel até a venda.
IPTU mensal, condomínio mensal e as parcelas do
financiamento.
Então, na soma total de custos, para a
tabela price, a gente ficaria ali com um
pouco mais de R$ 81.500. Na
tabela saque, a gente precisaria de um pouco
mais de R$ 85.000. Continuando com
a nossa análise aqui na calculadora, comissão do
corretor 6% e aqui já está o
cálculo do imposto de renda que você vai
pagar.
O imposto de renda vai ser diferente da
tabela saque para a tabela price, justamente porque
o que você pagou aqui de forma antecipada
também é diferente.
Aqui a gente tem uma linha do saldo
devedor do financiamento.
Por que existe saldo devedor do financiamento?
Na aula do módulo 2, que a gente
fala sobre a venda do imóvel financiado, você
vai saber que para você vender esse imóvel
financiado, esse saldo devedor deve ser quitado.
Não vai ser necessariamente quitado pelo próprio arrematante.
A gente vai fazer essa análise lá no
módulo 2, mas essa informação a gente precisa
aqui para analisar na calculadora do leilão.
Você vai precisar quitar esse financiamento e lá
no módulo 2 você vai entender como é
que de fato funciona isso aí na prática.
Então, para quitar o financiamento, para que a
venda acontecesse, você precisaria, na tabela price, de
um pouco mais de R$ 158.000.
Na tabela saque, você precisaria de menos, você
precisaria de um pouco mais de R$
154.000 e a diferença está porque na
tabela saque você pagou mais de forma antecipada.
Enquanto na tabela price, num primeiro momento você
tirou menos dinheiro do bolso, mas na hora
da venda o saldo devedor ali daquele financiamento
vai ser maior.
Então, a consequência dessa diferença do saldo devedor
é aquilo que você pagou durante o prazo
que o imóvel estava com você.
E por final, a calculadora já apresenta o
lucro que você vai ter.
O seu lucro seria um pouco maior na
tabela saque do que na tabela price.
E aí essa diferença você precisa saber, você
precisa fazer ali no seu caso prático.
Você vai analisar o lucro sabendo se você
quer ter um lucro maior.
Se você quiser ter um lucro maior, você
vai optar pela tabela saque.
Se você quiser ter um lucro menor, você
vai optar pela tabela price.
Essa é a diferença que você precisa saber
do lucro.
Mas você também precisa voltar aqui e analisar
a soma total dos seus custos, porque na
tabela saque você vai ter um custo maior
do que na tabela price.
Então se você quiser arrematar pagando mais, tirando
mais dinheiro do seu bolso, mas também lucrando
mais, opte pela tabela saque.
Se você quiser tirar menos dinheiro do seu
bolso para arrematar aquele imóvel e manter aquele
imóvel, mas o seu lucro vai ser um
pouco menor, faça a opção pela tabela price.
Então está tudo disponível aqui na calculadora para
que você verifique caso a caso o que
vai ser melhor para você desde uma compra
financiada na aba de pagamento financiado, desde uma
compra a prazo, uma compra optando por um
financiamento na aba de pagamento financiado.
E aí na aba de pagamento financiado, lembre
que existe essa diferença entre tabela saque e
tabela price.
E está aqui, a própria calculadora te apresenta
essas duas diferenças.